[Applaudissements]
j'étais costaud les deux kinés
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
tu
et
non
à
[Musique]
il
m
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien
chers amis
voici la dernière séquence de notre
rassemblement une séquence évidemment
très attendu puisque vous allez pouvoir
dialoguer avec notre président christian
jacob et avec notre président du sénat
gérard larcher alors je voudrais d'abord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je voudrais d'abord vous dire que vous
avez confirmé tout au long du week-end
que vous étiez bien le premier mouvement
de jeunesse de france
une jeunesse
une jeunesse de droite une jeunesse de
droite qui s'affirme et qui a confiance
en son avenir et je voudrais remercier
très chaleureusement guilhem et ses vice
présidents
parce que
ils ont organisé avec aurélien ce
rassemblement qui est d'ores et déjà un
vrai succès un grand succès je voudrais
aussi les féliciter nos jeunes pour le
travail de fond qui le qu'ils ont
réalisé ils ont un cercle de réflexion
dont ils vous ont parlé ce matin athéna
plus de 400 jeunes qui réfléchissent à
des propositions qui nous ont été
présentés ce matin et je voudrais
féliciter marie et théo qui nous les ont
présenté ce matin
des propositions innovantes des
propositions courageuses et dont nous
allons pouvoir nous inspirer pour notre
projet alors je voudrais vous dire que
nous les républicains nous ne
considérons pas que la jeunesse est une
part de marché électoral qu'il faut
capter en ayant recours à quelques
influenceurs de renom mais que nous nous
considérons la jeunesse et c'est le sens
de ce rassemblement aujourd'hui nous
avons voulu vous associez christian
jacob a voulu en faire un vrai mouvement
au sein de notre famille politique et
c'est véritablement le signe que nous ne
cherchons pas à séduire nous cherchons à
vous considérez vous associez parce que
au fond c'est sur vous que nous comptons
pour pour l'avenir
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais ajouter une chose j'ai été
frappée en lisant la presse ce matin j
ai lu quelques commentaires que je
trouve tout à fait intéressant et que je
vais vous livrer la droite relève la
tête pour la première fois de chez les
commentateurs on nous explique qu'après
tout c'est une perspective tout à fait
crédible que nous soyons deuxième tour
et que nous puissions l'emporté donc
[Applaudissements]
nous
nous en étions
[Applaudissements]
à
alors nous nous nous en étions
convaincus car comme cela a été dit par
damien abad ce matin au delà de notre
propre famille politique c'est bien un
courant de pensée qui a une histoire qui
s'est nourrie à l'aune des plus grands à
commencer par le général de gaulle et
dont nous pensons qu'elle a un avenir
mais aujourd'hui nous ne sommes plus les
seuls à le penser d'autres le pense
aussi et ils ont raison
[Applaudissements]
alors vous allez vous allez pouvoir
dialoguer avec christian jacob et gérard
larcher je voudrais tout d'abord vous
dire que aux côtés de christian jacob
depuis deux ans et dans la continuité du
travail que laurent wauquiez a fait la
tête du parti je veux lui dire en amitié
[Applaudissements]
et je salue son courage
christian christian a fait un travail
depuis deux ans un travail formidable il
incarne je crois tout ce que la macro ni
n'est pas d'abord l'expérience nous on
n'est pas des amateurs et on n'est pas
fiers d'être des amateurs
nous avons de l'expérience et cette
expérience nous la revendiquons parce
que nous voulons la mettre au service de
la france
christian c'est aussi la fermeté et
l'ouverture dans un savant dosage sa
demande des grandes qualités diplomatie
les a je peux vous le dire et c'est tout
à fait inverse d'un pouvoir autocratique
qui ne décide que par lui-même enfin le
gros atout de christian c'est d'être un
rassembleur un meneur d'hommes et un
rassembleur contrairement à un pouvoir
qui divise et qui fracturent alors
christian c'est aussi une volonté un
projet une stratégie d'abord pour vous
les jeunes nourris par son expérience
auprès des jeunes agriculteurs il a
voulu faire du mouvement jeunes de l air
un mouvement indépendant avec un
président un budget un projet qu'on
écoute et qu'on respecte
c'est à lui c'est à lui qu'on le doit
c'est à lui qu'on doit le ce
rassemblement aujourd'hui et puis
christian a voulu aussi travaillé auprès
des adhérents vous savez que notre
mouvement regagne des couleurs retrouve
des couleurs les adhérents reviennent va
tout simplement parce qu'il entrevoit
aussi la perspective de la victoire qui
est une nécessité pour redresser la
france et puis enfin christian c'est un
projet et c'est sur ce point que je lui
poserai la première question le projet
vous en avais beaucoup entendu parler
depuis hier vous y participer puisque
vous avez fait des propositions que nous
avons retenue et j'y reviendrai
ensuite
gérard gérard larcher le président du
sénat notre président et je voudrais
vous dire toute l'importance du sénat
depuis le début de ce quinquennat cela a
été dit par les uns et les autres
ce pouvoir a méprisé à négliger à
ignorer a abaissé le parlement comme
jamais et heureusement heureusement que
nous avions le sénat nous avons le sénat
pour corriger les textes erratique qui
sont examinées à l'assemblée nationale
nous avons
évidemment besoin du sénat pour rappeler
qu'il n'ya pas de démocratie accompli
sans débat démocratique et le sénat est
là pour nous le rappeler
c'est un contrepoids
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un contrepoids absolument
essentiel et déterminant au travail
vraiment très critiquable que cette
majorité a pu conduire et puis je
voudrais remercier gérard parce que moi
c'est bon deuxième mandat donc j'ai je
connais le fonctionnement du parti
depuis longtemps et je trouve que sous
ce quinquennat et sans doute poussé par
la nécessité de travailler ensemble et
bien avec gérard avec le président de
son groupe bruno retailleau avec damien
abad notre président à l'assemblée
nationale il y à un dialogue permanent
on essaie de construire des stratégies
des contre propositions
on n'est pas dans une opposition
clanique et au contraire c'est ce
travail sérieux de partenariat qui porte
ses fruits et je voudrais dire que le
travail avec avec eux christian jacob et
gérard larcher est animé par une seule
volonté tendus vers un seul but qui est
celui de la reconquête et du
redressement de la france alors je
voudrais
je voudrais chers amis
[Musique]
je voudrais que vous applaudit ciel ces
deux hommes qui sont des figures
majeures de notre formation politique et
sur qui nous savons compter christian
gérard
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien
donc on va alterner avec aurélien je
vais poser une première question à
christian christian dès que tu es arrivé
la présidence de notre mouvement tu a
souhaité engager tout de suite un
travail de fond sur sur le projet alors
tu vas nous expliquer pourquoi ce choix
qui n'a pas toujours eu la force de
l'évidence parce que par exemple les
médias leçons sont très peu occupé
jusqu'à finalement une date récente et à
force de leur expliquer de leur dire
quel était le fond de notre action ce
qui nous motive et ce que nous voulions
mettre en oeuvre eh bien je crois que
progressivement ils finissent par
s'intéresser je voudrais christian que
tous nous explique le pourquoi de cette
méthode est ce que tu en a tant
merci merci annie
quel plaisir de vous de vous retrouver
en ce début d'après midi j'aimerais vous
dire que j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
hier mais quel bonheur pour moi moi qui
était pendant très longtemps je disais
que j'étais le président de la première
organisation de jeunesse lorsque j'étais
le président des jeunes agriculteurs et
en arrivant aux responsabilités que vous
m'avez confié j'ai eu à coeur de faire
revivre un mouvement de jeunesse est un
mouvement de jeunesse ça se vit dans
l'autonomie c'est à dire vous n'êtes pas
là pour faire dit faire vous êtes là au
contraire pour bousculer pour avoir des
liens qu'ils soient bien évidemment des
liens des liens statutaire mais aussi
pour prendre toute la place qui doit
être la route et lorsque on a relevé ce
défi il y a deux ans l'année dernière
c'était une première on était déjà
content mais là on est très fiers et
vraiment je lis 10 ans commence en mai à
grand coup de chapeau à guilhem à toute
son équipe vous avez été formidables
et si j'ai voulu
c'est pas le fait du hasard vous savez
j'ai souhaité qu' il y ait ce débat
chaque intervenant avec la salle il y
ait un discours ce soir celui du
président des jeunes aient l'air pour
montrer aussi à nos amis de la presse
annie faisait référence à la fois que la
droite et d'un retour mais les jeunes
sont de retour et les jeunes sont de
retour à droite vous êtes là vous les
incarner
[Applaudissements]
alors
sur le rassemblement annie me lancer sur
ce sujet vous savez c'est de remettre
tout le monde autour de la table pour un
saint est un ancien syndicaliste comme
moi ça fait partie du job c'est à dire
qu'on aime le débat on aime la
confrontation
on aime aussi une vague et décisions
soient prises qu'elle soit appliquée et
j'ai voulu que l'on travaille de cette
manière avec aussi l'humidité qui doit
être la nôtre lorsque l'on enchaîné deux
défaites et on enchaînait deux défaites
donc il faut savoir en tirer les
conséquences et si nous avons depuis
deux ans renouer avec la victoire où
nous avons gagné chacune des élections
n'en déplaise à nos adversaires rien ne
nous a échappé
nous avons gagné les municipales
souvenez-vous de ce qui a été dit sur
les municipales on nous annonçait des
listes la république en marche partout
on nous annonce elle l'implantation du
rassemblement national ils sont où ils
ont disparu de l'échiquier sur les
municipales
on nous annonçait ensuite des
législatives partielles compliqué on les
a gagnés
on a remporté une formidable victoire au
sénat alors qu'on était déjà en
situation de force on amplifier le
résultat et ça c'est aussi l'union le
rassemblement
et puis la bad m de gérard larcher pour
donner l'accès date au rial
et puis après et bien après on a
continué avec les départementales et les
régionales et on a vu les résultats
auxquels nous sommes arrivés là aussi on
a amplifié nos résultats au
départemental on a gagné des
départements supplémentaires
et puis aux régionales quand on regarde
par rapport au score de nos adversaires
qu'est ce qu'on nous avait pas dit sur
le rassemblement national
la réalité c'est que la dernière fois il
était en tête dans six régions étaient
présents deuxième tour là dans une seule
ça veut dire que l'on a gagné le terrain
des idées et qu'aujourd'hui ils ont
montré que le front national était dans
une impasse et nous conduisait dans une
impasse c'est la droite qui reprend des
couleurs c'est la droite républicaine et
c'est ça que nous incarnons donc
vraiment je voulais vous remercier de
tout cela est de dire que le
rassemblement c'est comme ça nous
l'avons fait et nous l'avons fait par le
travail de fond quand je parlais
d'humilité tout à l'heure eh bien il ya
deux ans maintenant nous sommes mis sur
ce travail c'est à dire en disant on va
reposer à plat tous les sujets qui
préoccupent les français pas ce qui nous
préoccupe au quotidien dans nos sphères
politiques mais ceux qui font le
quotidien des français pourquoi on gagne
dans toutes les collectivités
territoriales c'est parce que on a la
capacité de présenter un projet qui
répond aux attentes de nos concitoyens
sinon on gagnerait pas et donc pour cela
il fallait prendre ce temps ce temps de
poser à plat toutes les préoccupations
de nos compatriotes de le faire avec
l'ensemble de nos parlementaires et un
grand coup de chapeau à nos trois
groupes parlementaires qui ont et force
de proposition d'initiative et qui
jamais n'ont laissé le champ libre à la
république en marche on a toujours été
force de contre propositions autant
l'assemblée nationale au sénat au
parlement européen nos trois présidents
groulx ont su faire entendre nos et
faire respecter nos nos couleurs donc c
était cela c'était aussi de s'appuyer
sur les élus territoriaux
j'ai voulu que ce travail de fond on le
fasse avec les mains avec les
conseillers départementaux avec les
conseillers régionaux qu'on y associe la
sio soucier la société civile combien
les corps intermédiaires ont été
méprisés par ce pouvoir et nous les
avons respectés nous avons accepté
d'avoir des débats ou parfois ne sommes
pas d'accord lorsqu'on fait venir aussi
h des républicains le secrétaire général
de la cfdt ça n'était pas dans la
tradition mais il faut avoir le courage
du débat d'idées il faut pas se planquer
il faut débattre avec eux nous l'avons
fait avec la cfdt on a fait avec le
medef on l'a fait avec des personnalités
aussi bien à dives et aussi différentes
que thibault de montbrial où l'imam
chalghoumi lorsque l'on a parlé
d'immigration c'est comme ça on montre
qu'on ne se plante pas on le fait en
transparence et c'est à partir de là
qu'on est capable de faire naître un
projet qui va à la foire attendre vingt
répondre aux attentes de nos concitoyens
c'est tout ce travail qui a été réalisé
avec des propositions qui ont été soumis
au vote des militants c'est pas 4 techno
sur un coin de table qui ont rédigé ce
projet ce projet c'est le vôtre
chacune des propositions qui alors a été
votée et soumis au vote des militants
une proposition est sorti de là et puis
c'est l'occasion aussi à la présentation
de ceux de ce projet de redonner un coup
de chapeau à la fois christine que je
vois là au premier rang et olivier qui
doit quelque part dans la salle pour
tout ce travail de coordination
merci à tous les deux vous avez été là
aussi formidable pour cette préparation
donc voilà comme on essayé de rassembler
donc maintenant on est sur cette
dernière dernière ligne droite qui est
celle de la de la présidentielle il
faudra l'incarnation vous l'a dit 50
fois vous le redire encore mais on
incarne sur quelque chose sur quelque
chose de solide et on voit bien que
quand on débat sur le fond eh bien il ya
beaucoup moins de différences de temps
en temps on a tous les uns les autres en
disant la main sur le coeur mes
convictions oui mais tes convictions
tous les mets sur la table et puis on en
débat et quand on débat est bien en
rassemble parce qu'on est capable de se
retrouver aujourd'hui lequel d'entre
nous ne se retrouve pas dans ce projet
mais tout simplement si on s'y retrouve
c'est qu'on a su prendre le temps de
cette discussion donc je voulais
vraiment remercier tous nos militants
qui ont participé et puis vous le
comprenez aujourd'hui a vraiment un coup
de chapeau particulier à vous tous à
tous les jeunes parce que vous avez
apporté une formidable contribution et
on est tous très fiers de vous
[Applaudissements]
merci merci beaucoup qui suit en jacob
notre président mes chers amis nous
sommes de retour
la droite républicaine est de retour la
jeunesse de droite est de retour et
depuis deux jours vous démontrer que non
seulement nous sommes pas morts mais que
nous sommes bien vivants et que les
victoires à venir nous irons les
chercher et des conquérir merci merci de
tout coeur à chacune et chacun d'entre
vous de nous avoir rendu si fier durant
ces deux magnifiques journées il n'y a
pas de grand mouvement politique sans un
grand mouvement de jeunesse vous êtes ce
grand mouvement de jeunesse
à celles et ceux qui se demandent encore
ce que nous avons en commun ils ont pu
voir depuis deux jours que nous avions
l'essentiel en commun d'abord nous avons
en commun un beau pays un grand pays un
pays qui a ébloui le monde durant des
siècles un pays qui porte des promesses
immense pour chacun de ses enfants ce
beau pays que nous avons en commun dont
nous sommes tous fiers dont vous avez
ici les drapeaux ce beau pays c'est la
france
nous avons en commun une promesse la
promesse républicaine
cette belle promesse qui s'adresse aux
gamins la creuse aux gamins du loto
gamin de trappes aux gamins de
versailles et qui a chacun lui dit si tu
veux réussir tu pourra réussir ton pays
te donnera la chance de trouver des
responsabilités et de participer à sa
construction nous avons en commun un
espoir monsieur le président cet espoir
c'est celui du rassemblement des
français la droite est belle quand elle
parle à tous les français la droite est
belle quand elle rassemble la droite est
belle quand elle est un espoir est pas
une punition voilà depuis des années
voilà depuis des mois qu emmanuel macron
nous a démontré que la division était un
poison dans un pays comme le nôtre
emmanuel macron à fracturer divisé
mépriser les français la droite
républicaine et celle qui continuera
demain à donner de la dignité de la
reconnaissance et du respect à chacun de
ses enfants monsieur le président
gérard tuer le deuxième personnage de
l'état tué un homme de fidélité un homme
d'engagement qui depuis des années aux
côtés de notre famille politique apporte
une pierre déterminante à la
construction et à la reconstruction nous
n'aurions pas les débats politiques que
nous avons depuis plusieurs mois nous
n'aurions pas la résistance que nous
pouvons avoir à la politique d' emmanuel
macron si nous n'avions pas gérard
larcher et je veux pour cela que vous
lui adressez vos applaudissements
[Applaudissements]
et
tu es aussi un homme de dialogue c'est
au coeur de la pensée politique de tes
actes politiques de ce qui a fait 11
chemin politique depuis quelques petites
années pour ne pas te vieillir il faut
que tu nous parles de ce dialogue
comment demain la droite républicaine
peut à nouveau redevenir un espoir et un
espoir de dialogue pour notre pays
d'abord d'abord cher aurélien
gerani
cher tous je crois que tu a prononcé
deux mots clés pourquoi on est là pour
quoi on s'engage
pourquoi on a un projet c'est parce
qu'il ya la france et la république est
dans les temps qui viennent
notre seul objectif
c'est notre pays ce sont les valeurs
républicaines que nous portons et je
voudrais vraiment vous le dire en
remercions très sincèrement
guilhem carayon et son équipe de nous
avoir permis cela
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui il m je crois que un mouvement
politique comme le nôtre a besoin d'un
mouvement de jeunesse
autonome d'ailleurs qui les cadres donc
faut mieux dire qu'ils sont autonomes
parce qu'ils prennent leur liberté et
ils ont bien raison je voudrais dire
aussi
un mot à laurent wauquiez qui est
présent aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu sais lors on a connu des tempêtes on
a connu des débats mais pour ma famille
politique je m'applique cet adage
les amis c'est comme les étoiles c'est
pendant la nuit qu'on peut les compter
et tu nous a conté
[Applaudissements]
alors
cher christian jacob
merci merci de la manière dont tu
présides notre mouvement ça n'est jamais
très simple mais tu as su transformer
nous rassembler en faire un espace
j'allais dire où le dialogue a du sens
où on va au fond des choses et où tu
d'une respecte en tant que vous fait un
petit coup de colère mais elle est utile
elle est saine et je dois dire que c'est
ça la réalité d'un mouvement vivant
alors je te le dis cher christian au nom
de tous je vois des parlementaires qui
sont là je vois de présidente de groupe
hier bruno retailleau était là je dois
dire que nous sommes autour de toi dans
notre diversité avec la diversité de
notre sensibilité et je te garantis que
dans les mois qui viennent nous devons
avoir qu'un seul objectif la france
gagner pour la france gagner pour la
république eh bien nous serons à tes
côtés
[Musique]
alors
[Applaudissements]
avant de gagner faut bosser
parce que
il a raison christian
une victoire n'était acquise que quand
nous avons la victoire idéologique et
c'est le projet que nous portons et
merci à tous ceux qui ont préparé le
projet merci à olivier à christine qui
ont donné à ce projet une force une
crédibilité et ce projet il sera partagé
il sera enrichir par celui ou celle qui
portera les valeurs qui sont les nôtres
alors aurélien alors je te remercie
parce que je n'ai jamais vu le sénat
autant applaudi dans une assemblée de
jeunes
[Applaudissements]
alors vraiment
[Musique]
je n'ai jamais vu un secrétaire général
du mouvement s'engager autant pour le
sénat merci aurélien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais revenons à ta question et aux
sujets
majeurs
c'est vrai notre pays
n'a jamais été autant fracturé archipel
is et comme le dit un auteur de qualité
et dans l'ouvragé a eu un grand succès
mais je vais vous conter
pas une anecdote mais publiquement le
souvenir d'une rencontre
à la veille
à la veille des cérémonies d'investiture
des manuels macron
celui ci bien à me voir au sénat c'était
une première républicaine je le dis ça
ne s'était jamais passé c'était la
veille
et il me dit comment
vous trouvez le pays
je dis monsieur le président de la
république il le sera totalement le
lendemain ce pays il est comme au
premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle
profondément fracturé divisée et un
président de la république il a un
devoir à devoir majeur être quel que
soit son âge le père de la nation qui
rassemble qui rassure
il réforme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'at-il fait de notre échange
vous savez
il ya deux mots
jamais notre pays n'a connu autant
la crise de la confiance
est d'ailleurs une partie
de l'abstention massive il faut la
rechercher aussi dans cette crise de
confiance
extrêmement profonde qui s'adressent à
nous mais qui s'adresse d'abord au chef
de l'état et je vous le dis à mes amis
il y a ça nous touche tous depuis dix
ans notamment une crise des résultats
voilà pourquoi j'ai
j'ai aimé que notre projet dès que
trente propositions
parce que je crois qu'il faut aller à
l'essentiel
il faut réformer il faut libérer mais il
faut aussi rassurer protéger 2d
confiance et autour de ça cette crise
des résultats je crois tout devront
avoir
les vraies propositions mais que nous
soyons en capacité de faire partager aux
français car sinon ils ne croiront plus
en rien le second des sujets
c'est que cette fracture elle est le
résultat de la verticalisation absolue
du pouvoir on n'en est même plus à ce
que les grandes décisions se prennent en
conseil des ministres elles se prennent
au conseil de défense elles se prennent
au tour de trois heures autour du
président de la république nous ne
pouvons pas continuer ainsi
nous avons besoin de subsidiarité de
proximité et mes chers amis je vous le
dis
je vous le dis si on ne sait pas
répondre courageusement
sérieusement un certain nombre de maux
de notre société
qui s'appelle jeunesse qui s'appelle
aussi insécurité qui s'appelle aussi
défi migratoire
qui s'appelle place de la france en
europe et dans le monde eh bien pourquoi
voudriez vous que les français nous
fasse confiance
et
qu'il quitte les chemins de la défiance
il ne faut premier point cher aurélien
retrouver
rebâtir la république de la confiance
alors mes chers amis
j'évoquais la verticalité au fond
ce cas qaîda qui va s'achever c'est sans
doute l'exercice le plus solitaire du
pouvoir
le plus solitaire du pouvoir
et je dois dire
qu'il a ignoré toutes les courroies qui
font une république qui font une
démocratie le parlement cher à nice tu
l'évoquer mais mes chers collègues élus
vous le savez parlementaire mais je veux
le dire aux jeunes savez vous que 52%
des lois adoptées depuis juin 2010 sept
l'ont été par ordonnance sans réel débat
au parlement dans l'ignorance du
parlement
est-ce que vous mesurez que les élus
locaux qui ont sauvé le président de la
république dans la crise des gilets
jaunes au fond
le président s'est parjuré
oubliant son engagement sur la
décentralisation sur la confiance aux
élus
conférence de presse d'avril 2010 9 et
au fond nous c'est en nous appuyant sur
les territoires en nous appuyant sur les
élus que nous pourrons me semble-t-il
rebâtir la confiance enfin aurélien
l'évoqué
le dialogue social au fond les
partenaires sociaux ont disparu pendant
cette période ils ont disparu parce que
eux-mêmes sans doute ne se sont pas
suffisamment réformer mais nous ne
pouvons pas dans ce pays ignorer le
dialogue social et je remercie christian
d'avoir en temps avoir fait un des
points importants
on peut être en désaccord avec tel ou
tel partenaire mais dialoguer c'est
finalement construire et rétablir la
confiance voilà ce que je voulais vous
dire je voulais vous dire à ce moment
avec le projet qui vous a été présentée
avec un travail que nous devons faire
dans un esprit de rassemblement avec la
lui si dit est aussi de se dire que nous
entrons dans une ligne droite nous ne
pouvons pas être les derniers à sortir
du virage comme dans la course de
poursuites parce que sinon nous
risquerions de ne pas être au rendez
vous et alors n'étant pas au rendez vous
c'est une partie des valeurs que nous
portons qui ne seront pas au rendez vous
avec la france merci de ce que vous
faites merci de votre engagement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et vous ne m'en voudrez pas d'avoir un
clin d'oeil particulier
pour les militants des yvelines des
jeunes républicains qui sont là et que
je salue avec amitié
[Applaudissements]
chaque question un mode de pose et la
seconde question avant que nous en
venions aux échanges directs avec la
salle souvent ceux qui te connaissent
tentant de nous raconter le parcours qui
un jour t'as poussé à s'engager en
politique ou delà du syndicalisme ce
parcours fait de rencontrer d'une
notamment celle de jacques chirac et à
mot qui revient souvent dans la bouche
qui je crois a du sens pour l'ensemble
des jeunes qui est ici ce mot c'est le
mot d'engagement et le mot de services
servir servir des convictions c'est ce
qui a marqué l'essentiel l'intégralité
de ton parcours politique comment
transmettre ce goût d'engagement ce goût
de servir quelque chose d'un peu plus
grand que nous notre pays et les
convictions auxquelles nous croyons toi
qui a su saisir la main lorsqu'elle a
été tendu par d'autres comment tu penses
que demain toi président du mouvement
d'autres responsables politiques ici
doivent tendre la main à ses jeunes pour
que l'engagement ça puisse aussi devenir
leur vie comme cet avis
c'est ce qu'on appelle une question
ouverte
plusieurs plusieurs choses moi ce que je
je constate et c'est aussi pour ça que
j'étais attaché à la création d'un des
mouvements jeunes au sein de notre
famille politique c'est que la jeunesse
ne manque pas de deux d'engagement mais
simplement on retrouve souvent nos
jeunes engagés sur des causes or je vais
le faire de manière un peu provocante
c'est facile de s'engager sur une cause
parce que on se retrouve entre personnes
qui ont la même conviction la même envie
au même moment et on est d'accord
finalement surtout donc c'est très
facile la différence sur un un
engagement politique ou dans du
syndicalisme à vocation générale c'est
d'aller se confronter à d'autres moi ce
que je dis souvent lorsque j'étais
responsable syndical et qu'il faut
arrêter une position entre le
viticulteur
de du languedoc que le producteur de
porc breton le céréalier de la l'abri ou
où l'éleveur du plateau de millevaches
là ça devient plus compliqué parce que
il faut avoir la capacité de rassembler
de faire une synthèse alors et le
consensus ça n'est pas quelque chose de
mou
celui qui arrive au consensus et celui
qui est fort c'est toujours beaucoup
plus facile de s'enfermer et de dire les
hôtes ont tort et moi j'aurai ce
uniquement sur ma ligne et et cela si ce
que nous pouvons faire rouiller un
mouvement politique comme le nôtre a
cette capacité de le faire et on voit
bien aujourd'hui ce que guilhem disait
hier en ouvrant la séance dix mille vous
êtes dix mille jeunes maintenant
adhérents jeunes républicains et bien là
vous avez cette force de faire cela
parce que vous venez de régions
différentes de départements différents
de milieux sociaux différents deux
parcours des deux formations totalement
différent et c'est par cette
confrontation et c'est comme ça qu'on
construit quelque chose et puis il faut
avoir la chance d'avoir des élus qui
vous tendent la main est sûr qu'un
certain moment j'en ai bénéficié on un
certain nombre en avoir bénéficié ça
aide d'avoir quelqu'un qui vous met le
pied sur la première marche du du
marchepied mais après il faut savoir
l'âme il faut savoir la saisir et puis
la capacité de faire ses preuves voyez
hier en accueillant en ouvrant ces
journées j'accueillais olivier capitanio
vous disait un mot sur olivier
c'est formidable victoire dans ce
département du val de marne 45 ans de
communisme ils ont gagné ils ont gagné
dans l'union ils ont gagné dans le
rassemblement mais ils ont gagné en ne
mettant jamais leurs mouchoirs dans leur
poche olivier tu es président de la
fédération et l'air et il a gagné le
département n'étant président la
fédération ait l'air et ça me donne
l'occasion de faire un vrai clin d'oeil
à quelqu'un qui est au premier rang à
faire un clin d'oeil à laurent parce que
là vous avez quelqu'un qui a jamais mis
son mouchoir dans sa poche et regardé la
victoire il a su remporter et puis
c'est aussi lorsqu'on est en
responsabilité je me tourne encore vers
laurent il m'a entendu le dire souvent
mais j'ai toujours plaisir à le redire
c'est que
cette victoire cette fois-ci c'est le
travail qui a été réalisé la fois
précédente on peut tous un moment ou à
un autre être élu par hasard on n'est
jamais réélu par hasard et la
démonstration qu'il a fait sur la
capacité de baisser les dépenses
publiques et en même temps d'augmenter
les dépenses en matière d'investissement
ça c'est un signe concret que nos
compatriotes et que ses compatriotes de
la région auvergne rhône-alpes ont bien
reconnu et c'est le défi qui doit être
le nôtre si nous avons gagné ces
élections c'est parce qu'on a été
capable de faire cette démonstration est
donc après nos échecs il faut donner
l'assurance aujourd'hui à nos
concitoyens contiendra nos engagements
d'où la nécessité d'avoir aussi des
engagements qu'ils soient sérieux et
raisonnable et tout le parcours de
l'engagement c'est celui-là c'est celui
de la force de conviction c'est celui
d'avoir le courage de se confronter à
d'autres qui ne partagent pas nos idées
c'est celui d'avoir le courage de faire
et d'assumer et aujourd'hui vous êtes un
grand mouvement de jeunesse vous êtes le
premier mouvement de jeunesse politique
en france ça n'est pas rien et donc vous
devez avoir maintenant cette exigence de
responsabilité sur les engagements que
vous avez pris la capacité de la tenir
et honnêtement pour avoir passé deux
jours avec vous j'ai pas beaucoup
d'inquiétude
bien avant que nous nous engagions le
débat avec la salle gérard je voudrais
te poser une seconde question tu as
évoqué dans ton propos la crise de
confiance tu as évoqué l'abstention qui
a atteint des niveaux stratosphériques
tu as évoqué un pouvoir solitaire qui a
divisé qui a fracturé notre pays toi qui
est un homme de dialogue un homme
d'expérience un homme qui connaît les
territoires qui connaît profondément la
france et qui ne la découvre pas comme
semble le faire le président de la
république quand il passe trois jours à
marseille
cher gérard qu'elles sont à ton avis les
principales conditions pour rétablir ce
climat de confiance pour redonner aux
français un espoir des perspectives pour
redonner confiance en la parole
politique et en actions publiques
bien je crois que ça se résume dans un
mot
retrouvé la proximité avec les français
et retrouver la proximité avec les
français
c'est de faire confiance faire confiance
à l'intelligence qui n'est dans les
territoires et je ne pose pas moi qui
suit c'était il ya bien longtemps les
grandes réunions du mouvement des jeunes
gaullistes mais qui croit en même temps
régalien à l'importance de l'état au
sommet
si nous ne partons pas de la réalité du
ciment de la reconstruction d'un lien
dans ce puzzle éclaté c'est la proximité
et je le dis devant des élus régionaux
départementaux
devant j'ai rencontré que les jeunes du
mouvement qui sont aujourd'hui sont
conseillers municipaux voire mer on a
entendu le maire d'erstein par exemple
hier et bien je vous le dis c'est
d'abord dans cette proximité retrouver
même si nous avons eu des élections
municipales dans les conditions qu'on
connaît chacun sait que la figure du
maire du maire adjoints des conseillers
municipaux
c'est la première des figures dans
lequel on rebâtit
confiance un deuxième des choses c'est
de retrouver tout simplement la voie du
respect des uns et des autres
j'entendais tout à l'heure quelques
propos tenus par le président de la
république
qui traduisait le mépris au fond si on
n'aime pas les gens
si on n'a pas un amour profond de la
france si on n'est pas attachée au
territoire si on n'a pas envie de les
servir nuno reconstruirons pas cette
france rassemblée dont nous avons besoin
alors mes chers amis pour être concret
pour être concret
il nous faut aller plus loin
d'or
dès l'élection dé la victoire un vrai
texte de décentralisation de
déconcentration de l'état de
simplification car j'aurais pu l'évoquer
nous sommes dans une société qui s'est
tellement complexifier qu'elle échappe
aux citoyens eux mêmes la complexité les
grands dépendants d'une forte de
technocratie et la seule manière de leur
faire retrouver cette confiance c'est
cela alors mes chers amis dans notre
projet nous devons avoir le courage
d'aller plus loin en matière de
confiance et en même temps de remettre
l'état dans ses missions essentielles la
question de la sécurité la question
de la maîtrise de l'immigration c'est
une réalité qu'il va falloir gérer la
maîtrise des dépenses publiques
j'entendais christine lagarde le dire
est ce qu'on peut
comme on l'a vécu avant même le qu'ovide
s'être engagé devant les français de
réduire la dépense publique et d'y avoir
augmenté de 80 milliards les trois
premières années de la présidence d'
emmanuel macron c'est autour de cela que
nous devons rebâtir me semble-t-il les
conditions de la confiance
merci hein
merci gérard
quelques mots en prolongement de ton
propos je veux dire à tous les jeunes
qui sont là certaines certains viennent
parfois me voir en disant voilà je
voudrais faire de la politique je
voudrais m'engager en politique
que faut-il faire je leur donne toujours
le conseil le même conseil engagez-vous
dans le mandat de la proximité le plus
merveilleux qui soit qui ait le mandat
municipal c'est là que tout commence
alors chers amis on va passer maintenant
aux questions de la salle donc
manifester vous
vous avez la parole merci beaucoup
alors merci beaucoup merci à tous
ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui mais qui
se portera sur du coup l'éducation
l'éducation
c'est un thème qui s'est imposée petit à
petit de plus en plus dans les sujets
qui intéressent les français aujourd'hui
on parle presque autant de d'éducation
qu'on peut parler de sécurité qu'on peut
parler d'immigration et je pense qu'on
est tous d'accord pour dire que l'école
ça doit être l'école de la réussite ça
doit être l'école de la rue de l'égalité
des chances ça doit être les cols du
mérite sauf qu'aujourd'hui
malheureusement on peut dire que l'état
a failli à cette mission là l'école ça
doit être l'école l'école où le fils
d'ouvrier le fise avocats se retrouve
avec les mêmes capacités les mêmes
chances pour arriver à ce qu'ils veulent
pour qu'on puisse favoriser cette
réussite sociale et donc ma question
c'est de savoir si demain notre camp
arrive au pouvoir et j'en suis convaincu
ce sera le cas avec ce qu'on a pu voir
ce week-end est ce que notre camp
portera enfin cette grande réforme
qu'attendent les français depuis des
années sur l'éducation et sur la
fracture scolaire qui aujourd'hui une
réalité dans nos écoles dans nos
collèges dans les lycées et même parfois
dans une université voilà merci beaucoup
merci à tous et à toi on va prendre des
groupes de trois questions
donc peut-être de show côté y at il
quelqu'un qui veuille oui mademoiselle
ceux déjà prête
alexandre a donc délégué national de sud
rail public tiens
j'ai passé comme ça voilà pour parler
près du micro c'est bon tout le montant
ça va voilà c'est bien ce que je vais
rejoindre bouton de la question qui est
posée est ce qu'après éducation à parler
culture ça n'étonnera personne de ma
part
depuis les années langue la culture est
une machine de subventions c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui tout est subventionné
avec la crise sanitaire on a bien vu que
et les activités culturelles artistiques
ont eu du mal à suivre est l'état a du
mal surtout à suivre au niveau
budgétaire et doit faire des choix donc
ma question est celle ci comment est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut assurer un avenir
aux activités culturelles artistiques
sans tomber dans tout subventionné et
plus largement comment est-ce qu'on va
réussir à construire un programme
culturel pour la droite en laissant une
place et aux arts populaires et à la
création merci merci beaucoup
à bout
l'un bonjour à tous je suis les eaux
garcia je suis conseiller municipal de
saint girons dans le département de
l'ariège qui est un département rose
dans une résidence d'une région rose
mais nous sommes déterminés à faire
basculer la couleur rose vert la couleur
du bleu monsieur le président du sénat
vous avez parlé des mers alors les
maires sur les élus préférés des
français
néanmoins force est de constater qu'ils
ne disposent pas de tout lit de tous les
moyens à leur disposition pour exercer
pleinement leurs prérogatives et prendre
des initiatives
alors quelle serait pour vous les pistes
de réflexion pour donner aux maires les
moyens pour qu'ils puissent
véritablement assurer le maintien de
l'ordre public et libérer les
collectivités territoriales du carcan du
centralisme merci beaucoup
on va en prendre quatre comme ça ça fera
deux pour chacun on équilibre bonjour
bonjour associons où tu te blesses où tu
montes le bras je te recommande la
sera plus facile alors alexandre wolff
saint malo si je suis
voilà je suis référent déjà le
républicain du bar à strasbourg et je
comptais du coup strasbourg c'est
l'union européenne c'est strasbourg
c'est le parlement européen et je vais
vous poser une question concernant
l'europe
la campagne présidentielle va être
rythmée par la présidence française du
conseil ça va être vraiment une vitrine
pour la république en marche et je
voulais savoir un peu quelle est notre
stratégie chez nous dans notre mouvement
pour essayer de aussi tiré profit de au
maximum de cette situation est aussi une
question qui nous concerne à strasbourg
est aussi tout à français comment faire
pour que notre mouvement et que et que
notre pays défendent le siège du
parlement sera à strasbourg donc voilà
je pense que c'est quelque chose d'aussi
très important pour nous voilà
qui commence question
[Musique]
alors je sais pas comment on fait partie
bon on va se débrouiller on a l'habitude
de faire ça peut de faire ça tous les
deux sur la première question qui était
sur
sur l'éducation bon c'est un sujet qui a
été largement débattue j'ai les experts
à côté de moi avec annie avec
françois-xavier devant et et beaucoup
qui en a qui ont vraiment participé
sur cette partie là moi je vais vous
dire deux choses sur l'or sur
l'enseignement tout d'abord il ya une
enquête que j'ai lu récemment je crois
que c'était la semaine dernière où nous
montre que 77 % des recruteurs
considèrent que les les qualifications
des jeunes ne correspondent pas aux
attentes du marché ce qui veut donc dire
qu'il faut aussi réorienter notre
formation sur un critère qui
l'employabilité et ça ça vaut notamment
sur le parcours universitaire c'est là
que la critique et était posé sur le
reste et bien avant cela est un sujet
qu'on a souvent évoqué qui celui de la
maîtrise de la langue française or on a
d'ailleurs on a une proposition sur le
sujet qui consiste à dire que le il faut
faire une grande cause nationale delà de
l'apprentissage du français tout
simplement parce qu'un jeune qui sort du
primaire qui arrivent en sixième qui n'a
pas une parfaite compréhension et
maîtrise de la langue française ne
comprendra pas les consignes et donc dès
la 6e dès l'âge de 10 ans eh bien on en
train d'en fabriquer ce que l'on appelle
après avec ce mot affreux un décrocheur
donc ça c'est le seul le premier point
qui pour moi est essentielle le deuxième
alors j'ai pas toujours été majoritaire
de ma famille politique sur le sujet
mais je vois que ça évolue et que ça
évolue bien dans nos propositions c'est
sur la suppression du collège unique et
la mise en place de l'apprentissage dès
14 ans on a réussi à créer toutes les
passerelles aujourd'hui c'est à dire que
vous pouvez passer d'un cap1 bac pro
d'un bac pro et bts d'un bts à une école
d'ingénieurs tout ça est possible mais
simplement il faut donner la possibilité
de mettre le pied à l'étrier très tôt or
tant qu'on ne libère pas les choses sur
l'apprentissage à 14 ans et qu'on ne
verse pas effectivement sauter le
collège unique on n'y arrivera pas donc
si je résume on a le français vraiment
grande cause nationale l'apprentissage
du français
l'examen en 6ème passage en 6ème de la
maîtrise de la langue française on a
ensuite sur l'élaboration des programmes
et notamment
sur l'éducation civique c'est été repris
très bien ce matin par par gilles
platret et bien pouvoir le faire tout au
long de la scolarité et ça ça veut dire
qu'il faut que ça fasse partie
intégrante pour raconter le récit
l'histoire française et qu'il y en ait
là aussi j'ai un agrégé d'histoire qui
fait oui de la tête au premier rang tu
contente mais tous ces points là c'est
comme ça qu'on va le reconstruire et on
va le reconstruire aussi avec davantage
d'autonomie sur les établissements
scolaires ça aussi que je sois au
collège au lycée et aux primaires il y a
besoin de cette autonomie et puis
dernier point sur les qualifications et
sur l'élaboration sur les diplômes y
associer davantage les fédérations
professionnelles quand on parle de
critères d'employabilité c'est justement
parce que aujourd'hui on a des
formations qui sont déconnectés de la
réalité du marché et si on n'accepte pas
de remettre le monde professionnel dans
le jeu pour l'élaboration des programmes
et pour l'élaboration en valeur
l'évaluation des diplômes on n'y
arrivera pas voilà quelques quelques
pistes sur cette première question
ensuite sur la
culture
deux points ou 3 points arbitres d'abord
reconnaître le travail qui a été fait
par la droite sur la culture la culture
nous pouvons être fiers vous savez nous
nous sommes ici au moins deux être des
adeptes du musée du quai branly on le
doit ça rentre lin d'oeil à aurélien on
le doit à jacques chirac le musée du
quai branly ce n'est pas rien en matière
de culture et puis la possibilité pour
tous les jeunes d'aller dans les musées
gratuitement c'est nicolas sarkozy ces
deux présidents de droite qui ont donné
des gestes forts direction de la culture
mais au-delà de ça moi je pense qu'il
faut vraiment renforcer le mécénat
le mécénat ça veut dire des abattements
fiscaux on va dire oui mais vous allez
encore faire des niches fiscales ça
coûtera toujours moins cher qu'une
subvention et donc on doit accompagner
davantage avec un mécénat qui permette
est bien de faire encore plus en
direction de la culture et puis il ya
quelque chose autre réflexion que j'ai
en tête c'est d'avoir comme il existe
centre national du livre
le centre national des artistes qui
permettrait avec un jury de
professionnels et d'artistes de pouvoir
accompagner des oeuvres ou des créations
d'oeuvres particulière et puis encore un
autre point mais il ya bien d'autres
propositions sur le droit de suite le
droit de suite - les oeuvres qui vont
sur le deuxième marché de façon à ce que
les artistes puissent continuer à
bénéficier de leur travail et de leur
création artistique voilà quelques-unes
des des pistes que sur lesquels on peut
être sûr la culture sur le reste je
passe le relais un gérard ou un mot
parce que on a parlé beaucoup
d'éducation ce matin dans notre table
ronde et christian vient d'évoquer
en quelque sorte la formation qui
conduit vers un métier vers un emploi
j'aurais peut-être d'un mot
revenir aux fondamentaux et on l'a vu
avec le premier confinement et
l'effacement de l'école l'école c'est
d'abord dans sa mission l'acquisition de
savoirs fondamentaux
et sa deuxième mission c'est
l'acquisition de fondamentaux citoyens
au fond c'est d'abord ça le rôle de
l'école est dans notre république
cette dimension des fondamentaux
citoyens elle rejoint aussi le combat
pour la laïcité la formation de la
laïcité républicaine
quand je parle des fondamentaux je vous
renvoie à un classement très
technocratique mais qui est quand même
le classement pisa de notre pays nous
sommes dans la petite moyenne 23e et
nous savons
que c'est d'abord liée à l'absence des
fondamentaux faiblesse en mathématiques
d intérêt pour la science
faiblesse pour la lecture donc je crois
que si nous voulons demain à voir des
jeunes qui s'adapte à tous les métiers
nous devons revenir à ces deux vocations
me semble-t-il de l'école culture
christian vient de le dire
il faut pas opposer une culture de
droite qui serait d'abord sécuritaire à
une culture de gauche qui aurait été
culturel c'est vrai que dans nos
fondements nous avons une culture du
patrimoine et je dois dire qu'il faut le
reconnaître c'est un élément très fort
du transfert des références et des
valeurs mais nous devons aussi et
georges pompidou nous en avait donné en
quelque sorte nous intéresser à tous les
éléments de la culture contemporaine
mais
mais aussi bien au street art à la bd à
tous ces sujets là mais il faut bien se
reposer la question de la culture
renvoyer aux territoires
aujourd'hui à ceux qui tissent de la
culture ça coûte cher ces trois et demi
pour cent du produit intérieur brut
c'est d'abord un partage et les élus le
savent entre l'état
les collectivités territoriales et
maintenant de plus en plus le mécénat
mais
ça n'est pas un investissement
secondaire ça n'est pas un
investissement second parce que la
culture c'est d'abord un facteur de
cohésion sociale et collective voilà
pourquoi il ne faut pas qu'on a réservé
aux élites mais il faut pas non plus
avoir le complexe de la culture
patrimoniale et d'une culture qui nous
mène vers le haut je pense que la
différence pour nous elle se situe dans
ces valeurs là je crois que la culture
est un facteur de cohésion ça doit pas
être second dans notre projet politique
dans mon expérience de maire j'ai vu que
l'importance de ce qu'on qualifiait ya
30 ans d'être la danseuse du maire je
vous rassure qui était un formidable
espace culturel c'est devenu la cohésion
d'une ville et d'un territoire à 50 km
de paris par la culture
sur l'europe
présidence française doit faire les
maires toi mr de
présidence française de l'union
européenne
c'est quand même assez bizarre nous
allons avoir une présidence française à
temps partiel
en effet président de la république
devrait avoir quelques préoccupations se
faire élire l'assemblée nationale à
partir de février va être en parle
il va rester le sénat pour assurer une
forme de continuité je pense une
première question pourquoi le président
de la république n'a pas fait à l'époque
comme le chancelier schröder qui avait
échangé avec la finlande la présidence
de l'union européenne car il avait
considéré qu'au moment des élections
législatives allemandes qui furent
anticipée à la suite il n'était pas
possible d'assumer pleinement la
présidence de l'union européenne
il n'a pas fait ce choix là parce qu'il
fait le choix que la présidence
française soit un élément du tremplin de
sa réélection
second sujet nous allons avoir des
dossiers majeurs pendant cette
présidence je vois des collègues élus
des français de l'étranger sénateurs
réélus aussi français de l'étranger nous
allons avoir
à discuter et la sphère afghane nous
ouvre qu'est ce que dément demain la
défense et la sécurité européenne
sujet majeur mes chers amis sujet majeur
nous avons bien vu et quelles que soient
les liens l'alliance que nous avons avec
les états unis d'amérique nous avons vu
en afghanistan qu'il décider seul et que
nous ne comptions pas ni l'europe ni la
france nous devons donc nous devons donc
prendre cette question de la sécurité de
la défense de l'union européenne
j'allais dire à bras le corps c'est
d'ailleurs le thème puisqu'il existe
quatre conférences parlementaire que
nous avons retenu pour le sénat pour la
réunion de l'ensemble des parlements de
l'union européenne avec un autre sujet
qu'est la question
de l'asile au plan européen et de la
question migratoire ne pourra pas
continuer à se cacher d'un sujet qu'il
faut traiter à la fois avec nos valeurs
humaines avec nos valeurs républicaines
mais avec la réalité que notre pays
n'est plus en capacité
d'intégrer d'accueillir et de faire sa
cohésion
je vous propose que nous prenions une
série de quatre autres questions il cinq
jours qui a répondu reçoit strasbourg
n'oublions jamais les croisements n'ont
su on n'oublie pas strasbourg les
alsaciens mais tous les autres soient
rassurés parce que l'enjeu il n'est pas
le sien pour strasbourg l'enjeu il est
français il est national c'est la place
de la france au sein de l'union
européenne et c'est vrai que c'est un
combat qui est difficile jeudi levant
françois-xavier puis l'ensemble de nos
parlementaires européens qui se bat bec
et ongles pour maintenir notre siège à
strasbourg c'est compliqué parce que
aujourd'hui on pèse moins lourd qu'on
peser au sein du ppe on sait pas ce que
vont donner les élections allemandes
donc mais raison de plus pour déborder
d'énergie sur ce sujet le siège du
parlement européen il est à strasbourg
et les nulle part ailleurs en tout cas
croyez la détermination ça et des
parlementaires républicains n'a jamais
manqué à la défense de strasbourg et
elle ne manquera jamais je le rassure et
nous nos amis sur ce sujet un dernier
mot sur les mers rapidement pour aller
vite sur cette question parce que je
vois leur qui tourne sur le rôle des
maires aujourd'hui il s'agit pas de
donner des pouvoirs supplémentaires on
peut toujours réfléchir c'est pas ça le
sujet c'est de donner la liberté au
maire de faire or ce gouvernement a une
idée en tête c'est de mettre les maires
sous tutelle c'est ça la réalité c'est
qu'à partir du moment on supprime la
taxe d'habitation
on supprime les recettes dynamiques et
on leur dit mais dormez dormez
tranquilles mangeant les braves gens ne
vous inquiétez pas on va compenser à
l'euro près mais on se fout de la gueule
des gens c'est ça la réalité on se fout
d'eux parce que bien évidemment on parle
à l'euro constant et ensuite on va
mettre un certain nombre de critères et
qui font que les maires vont devoir
aller quémander un soutien à l'état
alors que la réalité en bon paysan je
vous le dis moi c'est celui qui paye qui
décide et celui qui décide qui paye
c'est comme ça que ça doit fonctionner
donc l'un aux mails et mère sous tutelle
et c'est ça le reproche je fais et de la
même façon qu'avec l'ensemble des
collectivités territoriales ce qui a
animé la république en marche et le
président de la république c'est
uniquement savoir comment on peut les
mettre sous tutelle rappelez-vous
lorsqu'on avait eu ce débat des de folie
sur l'interdiction de cumul des maires
des deux mandats je vous le redis
d'ailleurs moi j'ai tenu à ce que je
sois dans le projet c'est que demain il
n'est pas question qu'ils aient une
seule catégorie de français qui ne
puisse pas siéger au parlement ce sont
les mères c'est inadmissible les maires
doivent réinvestir le parlement ils
doivent être présents à l'assemblée
nationale ils doivent pouvoir être élu
et qui plus est au sénat donc voilà ce
que nous dépendons sur les collectivités
il faut absolument redonner cette
dynamique et la dynamique c'est d'avoir
la liberté du choix des financements de
nos politiques c'est ce que nous
demandons tout simplement et c'est dans
ce sens là que nous avançons sur la
décentralisation fallait on a été trop
bavard quand même sont les maires car on
comprendrait pas que le président du cdh
à ne s'exprime pas sur les mers je le
dis devant des élus régionaux
départementaux et municipaux
à l'initiative de françois baroin
et d'hervé morin
et dominique bisman a été créée
territoire judy si un élément
extrêmement important lors on le sait
car s'il n'y avait pas eu territoire
juni je pense que la manipulation des
maires pour déplacer les élections
départementales et régionales auraient
marché parce que au fond
pour ce pouvoir
les maires ça ne sert qu'à ça et moi je
vous le dis il ya un vrai sujet pour les
mères d'abord qu'on doit gérer entre
nous les élus quelle part entre le maire
et l'intercommunalité quelle relation
pardonnez moi c'est un peu technique
avec les départements les régions ça
c'est mais aussi c'est essentiel
christian vient de dire s'il n'y a pas
une vraie autonomie financière une vraie
autonomie de recettes pour les
collectivités territoriales
je vous le dis clairement il n'y aura
pas de vraie liberté locale c'est ça le
sujet majeur
le maire c'est la proximité mais une
proximité au travail ou paralysées alors
notre pays ira encore plus mal
qu'aujourd'hui
merci monsieur le président vous propose
de prendre une série de quatre questions
je nomme monsieur
bonjour à tous ce matin et honnête tu
essayais wii fait exactement l'inversé
du président du parti et du président du
sénat
alors bonjour à tous je m'appelle taux
du trieux je suis militant dans le pas
de calais alors à titre personnel je
suis convaincu par la nécessité de créer
plus de places de prison afin que les
peines soient appliquées mais aussi
exécuté tout en mettant en avant des
peines alternatives comme les travaux
d'intérêt généraux quand cela est
possible pour que pour que c'est c'est
une certaine utilité concrète pour la
société avec des travaux qui sont faits
pour la société et donc ma question est
la suivante quelle mesure les
républicains peuvent ils mettre en place
pour assurer une politique pénitentiaire
efficace qui protège les français merci
merci beaucoup tu as la parole je vous
remercie infiniment de m'avoir donné la
parole 11 bruno je suis jeune
républicaine la sarthe alors très cher
président j'aurais une question sur
l'environnement comment allons-nous
financer la transition écologique et ce
par l'impôt par les taxes et qui seront
les premiers concernés s les entreprises
ou les particuliers je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
repartons sur notre droite
bonjour à tous je suis sourd et là j'ai
mon interprète alors je m'appelle
anthony bérard je suis adjoint au maire
du 13e et 14e arrondissement de
marseille moi mon objectif c'est au
niveau du handicap l'accessibilité et
l'inclusion sociale par contre c'est
vrai que j'ai beaucoup de demandes mais
là il ya quelque chose qui me tiennent
particulièrement à coeur c'est au niveau
de la langue des signes française qui
est souvent oubliée rejeté il n'y a un
grand manque d'accessibilité pour la
liberté de chacun et moi j'aimerais
avoir votre avis là dessus sur la
possibilité de vous faire reconnaître la
langue des signes française dans la
constitution française où nous
bataillons ardemment pour se faire
reconnaître comme étant français et je
vous remercie
merci beaucoup voilà bien beau combat
[Applaudissements]
tu as la parole
bonjour je m'appelle claverie bastienne
je reviens des pyrénées atlantiques je
suis adhérent et l'air depuis un an et
on a parlé on a parlé europe on a parlé
culture et j'aimerais à présent parler
ruralité
parce que il me semble que c'est un
sujet qui est un peu négligé de nos
jours
sujet mais compris plus que détesté mais
qui bien souvent dans les médias est mis
en avant avec de la grille bashing du
même du shass bashing alors on est un
chasseur moi même
je voulais savoir si par
quelques moyens comme des projets de loi
il était possible de mettre en avant
une utilité et même la nécessité de ces
de la culture de la ruralité ainsi que
les activités de la ruralité qui sont
nécessaires qui me semble nécessaire à
la vie de notre pays est ainsi que
ainsi que la nécessité de condamner tous
toutes les actions qui vont à l'encontre
de ses activités et voilà merci merci
beaucoup
question gérard tient
d'abord moi j'ai été très sensible à
la question sur le langage des signes
mais pour des raisons que je peux pas
vous expliquer
qui m'a appris à lire sur les lèvres
j'ai devant moi des membres éminents de
la commission des affaires culturelles
je pense au wip de la commission
on a des sujets de débats actuels mort
sur la langue les langues rien et
je pense que c'est peut-être l'occasion
de faire reconnaître aussi cette réalité
de la langue des signes je m'adresse à
mes collègues parce que c'est un sujet
dont on a très peu parlé et je pense que
le message qui nous a été transmis par
ce jeune élu de marseille il mérite
qu'on s'y penche qu'on y travaille et
qu'on voit comment on peut le
reconnaître je le dis parce que nous
avons ceux qui utilisent la langue des
signes et tous ceux qui connaissent des
déficiences et c'est un sujet que je
connais bien et nous devons me
semble-t-il nous en préoccuper je
voudrais vraiment vous remercier d'avoir
posé cette question aujourd'hui parce
que je vous dirais qu'on s'en est occupé
c'est pas vrai
transition écologique en sort d'un texte
sur lequel entre nous à n'y a eu parfois
des débats pour la transition écologique
qui en a vu avec le gouvernement
on a un sujet la transition écologique
christine lagarde et rapporteur
de l'environnement à la commission des
finances
c'est indispensable que nous nous
préoccupions de ce sujet et ce matin
c'était une des conclusions damien abad
il a dit faut prendre ce sujet à bras le
coeur et c'est un défi pour nous tous
mais encore faut-il
qu'elle soit socialement acceptable en
effet le principe de taxation nous
renvoie la crise des gilet jaune et nous
renvoie à la réalité comment est-elle
supportable nous allons avoir à vivre
une transition écologique qui va nous
toucher dans nos territoires une
transition écologique qui va nous
toucher dans la formidable
transformation
de la fin du moteur thermique pour
d'autres énergies et cette réalité va
pas être sans bouleverser il y avait des
jeunes tout à l'heure de haute marne je
peux leur dire que par exemple les
fonderies vont être bouleversées dans
les dix ans qui viennent il faut donc
qu'on prenne ce sujet à bras le coeur
mais en même temps que nous mesurions
bien l'acceptabilité sociale sociétale
d'une transition qui ne seraient que sur
la taxation de la consommation nous
aurons la présidence française de
l'union européenne si lors de cette
présidence on n'avance pas sur la
question du marché carbone et du marché
aux frontières monsieur le président de
notre délégation parlement européen
alors on aura raté un rendez vous majeur
nous devons sommet de glasgow au moins
de 9 ans être les porteurs de cela il
faut que la france soit en exigence
c'est ça l'esprit européen ça n'est pas
des frontières ouvertes à tous vents
c'est la reconnaissance de la
compensation voilà mes chers amis ce que
je pense
sur ce sujet mais peut-être sur la
ruralité on a le meilleur on a le
meilleur c'est christian
merci merci gérard
j'ajoute un sur la transition écologique
et sur un sujet qui a été évoquée ce
matin à la table ronde
sur l'activité économique
les principes du développement durable
je pense qu'il faut vraiment qu'on soit
chez les républicains les défenseurs de
cette logique du développement durable
et du trépied sur lequel on s'appuie le
trépied c'est d'abord la rentabilité
économique c'est à dire qu'un projet ne
peut pas exister dans le temps s'il ne
trouve pas ça rend une rentabilité
économique le deuxième élément c'est
qu'il doit être facteur de progrès
social ça veut dire que ceux qui
travaillent doivent bénéficier du fruit
du travail et là on revient sur un sujet
qui qui qui nous tient à coeur la
rémunération et la valorisation du
travail et le troisième élément le
respect de l'environnement parce que
c'est ça qui assure la durabilité du
projet donc il faut à chaque fois qu'on
repose les choses sur ce sur ce trépied
et là on sera solide et ça permet de
développer tout ce que gérard évoqué sur
la transition où on soit à la fois sur
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique tout en en prenant en
considération la situation telles
qu'elles sont c'est à dire ce n'est pas
la france seule en inventant des
contraintes pour ces entreprises qui va
apporter une solution on sait bien qu'on
évite dans un cadre européen d'où l'idée
de la taxation carbone sur l'art sur la
ruralité pourrait dire beaucoup ce que
l'on évoqué sur les les mères tout à
l'heure nous on est une proposition qui
épiait simple c'est de dire qu'à chaque
fois qu'un euro est engagé dans la
politique de la ville un euro doit être
engagé dans la ruralité ça permet tout
simplement de pouvoir équilibrer les
choses
parce que à chaque fois qu'on nous
explique qu'il faut fermer des services
publics à chaque fois c'est dans les
territoires ruraux quand on ferme une
école une classe ça n'a pas la même
conséquence quand on la ferme en ville
on ferme une classe on ferme de classe
on ne remet pas en cause l'école
lorsqu'on ferme une classe deux classes
dans les territoires ruraux on remet en
cause l'école et à partir du moment où
on a plus d'école dans une commune eh
bien on perd la vie dans cette commune
ont péri lors le renouvellement d'où le
fait d'avoir des politiques qui soit
différenciée comme on a su le faire sur
la politique de la ville il faut
aujourd'hui une politique différenciée
et d'accompagnement sur les territoires
ruraux et ça doit passer aussi par la
proximité et ceux qui maîtrisent le
mieux cette proximité ce sont bien les
départements et les régions mais aussi
qu'ils aient les moyens de le de le
faire je reviens pas sur les places de
prisons rachida a répondu très largement
là dessus l'élément essentiel c'est bien
évidemment l'effectivité de la peine
mais la capacité aussi de faire en sorte
que la peine soit choix effectués et
dans les propositions qui sont les
nôtres bien vous verrez combien on
laisse une place importante sur le
régalien et combien effectivement il
faut mobiliser des financements on va
peut-être laissé lors des mots sur les
prisons parce qu'on tiendrait pas on à
63000 aujourd'hui personnes en prison le
taux de remplissage
c'est horrible ce mot
110%
il faut donc construire et places de
prison mais ça suffit pas il faut que ce
pays retrouve confiance dans sa justice
plus 60 francs % des français n'ont pas
confiance dans la justice et pas
uniquement sur les grandes affaires sur
la justice du quotidien sur la justice
civile il faut donc que nous
rebâtissions dans notre projet à l'image
d'ailleurs de la proposition qu'avait
fait philippe bas avant 2010 est il faut
retrouver la confiance dans la justice
et retrouver la confiance dans la
justice c'est rétablir aussi l'état de
droit si l'état de droit n'est pas
respecté à ce moment là c'est la
république qui s'en ira et c'est là
dessus qu'on doit être mobilisé
maintenant on va céder la parole aux
meilleurs d'entre nous au président les
jeunes républicains c'est bien ça merci
monsieur le président je vous demande
d'applaudir notre capitaine christian
jacob président des républicains
notre président du sénat merci aux
différents présidents des groupes
parlementaires présents ici vous me
permettrez pour terminer d'adressés
aussi comme vous l'avez fait des
remerciements à l'ensemble du bureau des
jeunes républicains qui a fait un
travail formidable et si vous le voulez
bien j'adresserai aussi les
remerciements à laurent wauquiez laurent
c'est dans les moments où
vague est lourde c'est dans les moments
où l'on sait s'il faut prendre la mer ou
pas qu'on voit les vrais capitaine tu as
su faire un choix quitte au nord qui
nous honore et qui nous rend fiers de
notre famille politique et de ce que tu
es merci
et nous appelons sur la scène guillem
carayon
[Applaudissements]
oui